[Music]
let's go to chris in omaha what's up
christopher
how are you sir good to be here thank
you brother what's up man
man it's an honor um so i am a former
teacher uh i now uh i'm an author
speaker comedian i work with a lot of
schools in building resilient kids uh
mentally social emotional learning uh
that that whole realm
and um
i i know uh oppositional defiance
disorder uh i know it's a clinical
diagnosis but
uh myself and my wife as you know a good
christian parents we like to think of
ourselves um
i
i'm looking for your opinion um wait
hold on you like to think of yourselves
as what
good parents as good
good christian parents all right good
christian
i can't wait for this you set it up well
so what's the
one for the payoff here
i'm wondering uh your your professional
opinion oppositional defiance disorder i
know it's a clinical diagnosis but
where
i i guess my question is
it seems like it
it's more of a of an excuse
over the last number of years for
a lack of parenting skills uh at least
from from my vantage point and i'm just
looking to get your opinion on that
where you stand on on stuff like that
okay um so i'll give you a rundown but i
want to make sure the line is clear here
so
as good christian parents you're raising
your kids
to fill in the blank when it comes to
behavior and response and all that and
since their fault they are living up to
your expectations that you're setting as
good christian parents other kids are
out of control
exhibiting these behaviors at school
um
lashing out you know being ugly with
teachers violence those kind of things
and the line is back to
people who aren't serving as good
christian parents is that kind of is
that is that the tr is that the line
here i want to make sure i'm answering
your question
well the line is more of uh it seems to
me that the the boundary has been moved
back to kind of make a
an excuse for the disrespect the
um
uh
i guess the overall disrespect the
behavioral issues and they've put a
label on it now of you know the
oppositional defiance disorder gotcha
okay
okay so
i'm gonna start by by answering it this
way
uh i may have i don't know if i've told
this on the show or not i don't
i don't know i feel like i repeat myself
all the time maybe i don't
so when my son was born um i just
graduated with my first phd and there's
nothing worse than someone who just
graduated to the graduate school the
worst i was an idiot i just put it on
everything on my email signature told
everybody i was i was annoying
and my wife has a phd she's brilliant
and her scholarship her research was
about um working with kids
and so when my son comes along
we were older we waited a while and then
it took us years to
actually have him
he comes along
and he's pretty much perfect we were
incredible
and i remember at some point at like age
two or three
i was like
i think every other parent's an idiot
um
why are we even working at universities
we should go on the road and write the
greatest parenting book because everyone
else is stupid
and my wife in her classic way she deals
with me is she just nods and just goes
on about her day because she knows that
she married
a [ __ ]
and
i really was like man why is this so
hard like just to have high expectations
and then have high discipline and have a
high accountability and
whatever
and then my daughter came along
and i don't know where she's from it is
not here it's not here and i realized in
short order oh we just rolled the dice
well the first one actually we've rolled
the dice incredible with my second one
too they're just different kids so i
prefaced it with that to tell you this
i think like adhd like oppositional
defiant disorder like
much of anxiety depression is out there
on its own so i'm not going to mess with
that one in this call
because that's got all kinds of other
things going on with it
i think a number of these diagnostics
are
have turned gone from label to
i'm trying to think of the right word
off top of my head label to
core issue
instead of representing an environment
okay so what you're at what your
question is i think is not really the
right question because you're asking an
either or question is this real or is
this if parents would just suck it up
and start parenting their kids right
this would go away and the answer is
more complex than that
i'll answer
true odd yeah you know me true
oppositional defined disorder right
it's a diagnosis in its
there is no test for it there is no you
can't take draw blood for it right it is
not rendered lightly
to quote an article it's not rendered
lightly it is it takes a while to come
to this this thing
and so now especially in schools we do
have people who throw this label all
over the place no question about it
if you've ever met a truly odd child you
go oh
so to answer is it real yes
is it over um
diagnosed
i think probably 10x
but here's where that i don't like
saying that out loud
because it's the kids who pay for it
not their school systems and not their
parenting systems and not their
grandparenting systems and not their
legacy trauma issues
because when we say something like yeah
you don't really have options for
oppositional defiant disorder
we take a dysregulated child and a
dysregulated child is just telling you
they're not safe and they're not
connected and they're not okay they've
got nobody looking out for them they've
got nobody on their team
and that can be everything from a school
that starts at 6 15 a.m and the kid has
no sleep
because mom is working three jobs and
the babysitter maybe shows up most of
the time and brings a half a box of
macaroni right so you've got nutritional
you've got sleep you've got supervision
you've got all kinds of things
that has a stable parenting home of two
where
y'all make enough money that somebody
that things are able to happen in a
certain way okay so that's my loose
answer to say
yes when it's real it's super super real
super real
like chemically neurologically real and
i think many kids are desperate for
boundaries desperate for accountability
but underneath all that they are
desperate
to be looked in the eyes and told they
are loved and to be shown they are loved
through food and sleep and
accountability and hard work and
throwing a ball and moms and dads
putting their cell phones down
and grandparents not um abusing mom and
dad still is that you hear what i'm
saying now
yeah absolutely and that kind of where i
was
leaning i just
you know i wanted to hear the
professional opinion yeah um
but yeah i agree probably you know way
over diagnosed but there are legit cases
and i
so i am fat i'm joining a chorus of
professionals
who are moving
wholesale away from 95 percent of
diagnostics because they're simply not
helpful number one
number two
you've got
uh it's not like you take a strep test
you go to any number of counselors and
they're gonna give your psychology
they're gonna give you different
diagnostics or depending on which
inventory they give you they're gonna
come up with so
that whole the whole spectrum of
diagnostics i think is is under fire
here and it should be
and i think the the chorus of blame so
if you hear my show i rarely blame i
rarely go after like you parents need to
and except when it comes to cell phones
and screens yeah then i get after people
but
it's bigger than that so instead of
saying hey you know what you just did
you did this what i want to do is i want
to give people a bunch of tools and say
make your kid go to bed at 7 15
until they're in high school or 7 30
or absolute max 8 and they're gonna
think it's child abuse or if you miss
hanging out with your kid because you
don't have community or you don't have
these things um
make your kids
do chores which means
this happened to me the other day i got
i went into my son's room i was like
what like how do you live like this and
i walked down the hall into my room and
i thought
i learned it by watching you dad right i
have to i have to do these things too if
i say don't walk past the dogs bowl when
does that have any food and water just
fill it up then that means i got to stop
and do it every time right so i'm
talking about let's give parents some
tools and grandparents some tools and
communities some tools and schools some
tools for wholesale change
not just saying that's not even real
y'all need to suck you hear what i'm
saying
yep absolutely all right so that's my
that's my
it is real it is over diagnosed i think
the important thing to do right now is
to tell kids that we love them and to
show them we love them
and god i can say that over and over
again show your kids you love them
show your kids you love them
hold their hands read their dumb stories
put your phones away
let them mow the yard with you even
though it's gonna take eight times
longer let them clean the car with you
which is gonna take a thousand more
years and you can't cuss when you find
old gum in the seat you just gotta take
it because you're gonna be a grown-up
my son and daughter came and said hey
can we climb up on top of the barn we
stacked a bunch of buckets together and
i was
how about y'all use the ladder
i didn't want them but they need to do
hard things they need to be able to fall
down
love your kids show them that you love
them